pharmacists taking deliveries of the
pfizer vaccine are getting a pleasant
surprise as it turns out
there are up to two extra doses per vial
which the fda says are safe to use
errol barnett was the first network
correspondent to report on this kudos to
earl on that today
he's in cleveland reporting from one of
the city's hardest hit hospitals
when lieutenant delmar henderson
escorted the fisa vaccine at cleveland's
metro health hospital wednesday
he knew he was part of something big a
good day this is history
but even the farmer says thawing and
mixing the vaccine had no idea just how
big a moment
it would be i'm having trouble going
even more than a few minutes today
without crying
dr brooke watts is the chief quality
officer here and was among the first to
realize
they were more than the expected five
doses of vaccine per vial
the manufacturer as we understand it was
trying to be particularly cautious they
wanted to make sure
that each dose was full and there was
room for air but what we've learned from
our colleagues around the state and
country
is that if you follow the manufacturer's
directions very specifically
you actually have six full doses in each
vial that means
hundreds of additional doctors nurses
and support staff
like janitors and security can be
protected against the virus
it's a miracle responding to cbs news
the fda
issued this statement writing quote it
is acceptable to use every full dose
obtainable for 6 or possibly even a
seventh
from each vial meanwhile pfizer
responded saying
at this time we cannot provide a
recommendation
on the use of the remaining amount of
vaccine
and behind me you can see hospital staff
spending another 12 hours vaccinating
everyone
up right now first responders now all of
this is happening
while the hospital's covered wing has
three times as many patients right now
as it did during the worst outbreak in
the spring
and for those who celebrate you'll know
last night was the seventh night of
hanukkah
commemorating a time when one night's
worth of oil lasted eight
and that's why for dr watts she said
this dosage discovery
is this hospital's hanukkah miracle
anthony yeah you
sure can call it that errol thank you
that's great news those additional doses
especially right now